today's topic I'm gonna call it a little
bit like crime and punishment what does
that mean it means that sometimes even
the best players in the world
allow themselves to go a little crazy
and play a really strange opening and
sometimes they played against such a
strong opponent that they get really
punished for it and this will be today's
example and the player who lost this
game is none other than the u.s. number
one player and number four player in the
world
runner so you Kara Nakamura that's a
game from ten years ago he was still
very high rated about twenty six sixty
or something yeah and nonetheless he's
playing a Russian Grand Master but name
of Andre Volo Keaton and he tried
something very ambitious very how should
I say unusual in the opening something
that all of you probably know is him
know now and watch what happened that
game became really really exciting then
we will see a nice actually it's more
composition than a combination so II for
c5 so far the game starts very normal
but now he can when 2005 was very
experimental he plays something very
very strange anybody want to guess the
next move even a grandmaster at 26 60
sometimes like to be a little foolish he
did that he went Queen age 5 he really
in a real tournament game and he did it
more than once okay so now the game
really begins now we're gonna think okay
this is a really strange move the Queen
is coming out too soon and a grandmaster
is doing it we have to respect it the
could the Queen is attacking the pawn on
c5 I don't know if this is duck at the
end of the world because black can sure
get a lot of time if white is going to
start taking pawns and then come back
with the Queen when it's attacked so to
begin with I don't know if this is such
a crazy it's just such a great idea but
in that event he decides to play Knight
f6 and he says okay if you take my pawn
I'll take your center point on e4 so be
my guest do your worst
and the card says now
interested I'm just going to put my
queen where it's safe for the moment
defend my Ipoh on and my queen is
already kind of in an attacking position
so now maybe white wants to push his
pawn to e5 that could be a bit annoying
so voila keeping plays very logically
you'll see that black played this game
for the most part in a very logical but
very aggressive way using both
principles but also a lot of imagination
so Bishop b2 again kind of a strange
decision in my opinion because there
like a lot of moves here you can play
you can play your night out for example
you can play c3 at the right time okay
he decides to play Bishop e2 it's almost
like he's telling his opponent I'm going
to play all those funny moves you cannot
predict and you can do anything to me
but his opponent says oh really
let's see so ii v normally when we make
a move like this we have to be very
careful because we are weakening other
squares right now there's no point that
will defend the square anymore for black
but as you can see that square is so
much in the control of the black pieces
that he's gonna go d5 next move he
flight wants to play the move c4 he can
do it but then my knight is ready to hop
to one of those squares and I don't
think that this is gonna be a lot of fun
for white so d3 Bishop e7 already the
bishop is I'm a good square tickling the
Queen on h4 like I'm always every move
is gonna have to think what if what if
the right is gonna move so Hikaru says I
don't want to do that Queen to g3 again
it looks like a very aggressive move
he's attacking the pawn on g7 so some of
you might say well maybe it's time to
cancel but Val Keaton said no I'm not
going to cancel just yet because I
realize that if you take my pod on g7
and I'm gonna go rook g8 first of all
I'm starting to change the Queen around
and I can always get my own pawn on g2
which is also free for the taking
so why do I need to defend my pawn if
I'm not really attacked okay so he
played BAM d5 I have to say that so far
I'm a lot impressed with the way black
has played this opening then white white
moved his Queen to h5 then even
to h4 then he movie to g3 the stream
moves with a queen in the meantime blog
developed both his Knights his Bishop to
e7 and he has as good at center as you
can build II dc5 no wonder that black is
probably better in this position so
white played Knight to d2 again
defending the pawn on e5 e for that was
attacked and now black says okay now
that unite is blocking the bishop in
other words before let's say on castles
maybe maybe white could have played some
temper move like Bishop here gaining a
tempo noticed he cannot play in at age
five so you'd have to play 98 then maybe
white can just develop his piece and the
bishop can always go back if the King
knows so black was a bit smarter I think
about that first of all he hit in the
center would be 5
when white defendant and blocked his
Bishop then he decided to cancel that's
a good move water and white played c3
well because maybe he doesn't really
feel like seeing this Knight jumping to
d4 or before okay so far the game grows
interesting so now black said to himself
all right I have control of the center I
have three of my four minor pieces
developed that's pretty cool
I'm not sure exactly what I want to do
with the bishop on c8 am I gonna just
put it here is that the best score for
it and if not where else am I going to
put it so maybe I just wanna wait for it
and he said okay where do I have an
advantage you have an advantage in the
center towards the Queen side so when
you have an advantage toward towards the
one side then it's a good idea to start
gaining the space there so b5 very very
logical move gaming space controlling
most squares and that poor maybe the
right time feels like advancing to b4
and doing some tickling right or maybe
later on I will push my pawn to d4 like
happen in the game and I'm ready for a
break into something yes Arjun kind of
yes so in this position white is already
in thinking mode because everything is a
bit stuck if you move this night then
you're gonna lose this pawn I'm gonna
take it twice as long as you don't
this night that Kim moved his bishop and
as long as I came of this bishop my rook
in the corner is gonna look funny on the
other hand my king is stuck in the
center my rookies in the corner and my
knight hasn't been developed so my first
inclination is okay let's develop the
knight and attack the pawn but he didn't
do it he went night here what would have
happen if you would have played here I
want to see hands up if you know it why
didn't you just develop like a normal
person Knight f3 towards the center
looks like such a logical move I'm
definitely looking for more than one
hand here I want you to look at the
position use your imagination and think
this is such an obvious move if we
didn't play it he must have had a really
good reason not to play it yes
Knight - that is quite right Knight to
h5 and hmm what's happening with his
queen can we see a little bye bye Sonya
the queen is going bye-bye
exactly you can lose your queen where's
the Queen gonna go not good so now we
understand why he had to play Knight to
the rim even though he's not so proud
about that he still played it so I'm
gonna play now a move for black and I'm
expecting one of you to raise your hand
and give me an opinion why did he play
this move what is the point of this move
very good he's inviting of course pawn
takes knight eggs and he puts a lot of
pressure at the right time he might want
to take on XIII and the deep one and C
pond are going to be very very weak very
difficult position he also wants to do
something like pawn takes pawn takes
then b4 and once that happens the d4
pawn the d4 square is completely in
blacks control and guess what
mischievous Knight is going to jump
right into it
this one so white said okay I'm not
happy again let me close things up a
little bit so how many of you think that
we need now to really do something about
our be pawn how many of you are in panic
we are about to lose our be pawn we have
to do something about it
anybody nobody that's good news don't be
in panic the b-pawn is not important now
everything is about the element of time
doing things before white gets organized
and trying to get the initiative so
there are several good moves here I'm
going to play another move for black and
again I would like somebody to help me
by interpreting it this is a great move
the computer by the way gives it the
best mark he thinks it's the best move
into position maybe if I would have
asked you there I would have gotten all
of answers I don't know if I would have
gotten many answer saying 98 but this is
a fantastic move this move has several
good ideas who can explain them to me at
least three reasons no less three
reasons why this is a decent move let's
see if you can tell me one by one you
don't have to tell me oh I can all three
are John correct for a go away one at a
time he wants to play 96 the knight on
d6 is great he's hitting the pawn on c4
he's also defending b5 that's a good
idea sometime tonight on this it can be
really supportive of the Sun Turkic side
Queen side that's one thing what else he
wants to play Bishop h4 activate his
sleepy Bishop on e7 and bug that Queen
that is already not very happy where it
is very good point and the third one
while you move the knight away from
where it was one more thing that you
might achieve Arjen
um not really the night you already
agreed prop is gonna land on d6 there's
a good square for it yes yeah you want
to push the pawn to f5 at some point you
want to just open things up and all of
those things somehow happen in this game
although you will notice the block was a
bit careless at one moment but
nonetheless it was an interesting game
so he took on b5 I don't know if this
will be my first choice but it's really
hard to suggest anything here what can
you suggest if this knife moves to d2
finally then pawn takes pawn is very
annoying and block is gonna have a
protected passed pawn this Knight is not
going anywhere the queen is not really
going anywhere and I think he was maybe
thinking am I sure I want a castle here
is it absolutely urgent so he decided to
take and now BAM attack on the Queen
temple now white played a very fast move
here because he doesn't have that many
squares for the Queen you have to go
here and now he played BAM saving the
knight and threatening a little visit to
see to you with a beautiful fork well
what to do now they ship d1 that's right
he played Bishop do you want now black
play the move that I didn't like so much
it's hard to blame him I think that
maybe in a game many of us would play
that move he played our five and I think
this is not as good I think this is not
it looks scary but it's not really as
scary
what do you think should have been
played here instead let's hear if any of
you have any ideas of what should I play
there's one move here that I especially
like notice that white is threatening a
three I'm threatened to play the move a
three and then where is this Knight done
before going out of the board right so
if I'm gonna give the night it's gonna
be a good reason or maybe I have a move
that I don't feel like giving the night
but then I have to think of how I want
to build my structure yes yes
Quinn 85 it's interesting but I mean I'm
guessing that the Queen now is kind of
committed to the other side right maybe
now I'm complaining with white queen age
five and attack the bishop and the pawn
on d5 at some point so and I can counsel
probably when your queen is on a five
then I'll gladly Castle kingside
yes a six that is the move that I would
have liked to see a six I think it's a
great move it's almost like in the Banco
gambit I don't know some of you who
might play it you just give a pond to
open all kinds of files and diagonals
and what do you do if you play a three
I'm just gonna go ATX b5 you cannot take
my knife my rooks are my rook is pinning
your rock if you take on a six then my
bishop from c8 BAM
goes right into the game to a six and
the pawn here is already crying crying
hard right so a six would have been my
favorite move but follow keeping decided
that he's gonna sacrifice a piece and
gonna make a real mess out of it and
well he succeeded but he Carroll had
better chances at some point he could
have done better
so f5 very very strong attack on a4 but
unfortunately he played a three and now
1986 force the knight has nowhere to go
from before so he took it and he played
one takes double attack on the queen
with the pawn on e4 and the rook and f8
so he played queen h5 good move
very nice now again Black has to make a
decision yes he's down the piece but it
is obvious that he's attacking like a
madman and he's thinking who I'm
attacking f2 and my bishop and my work
but unfortunately there's a knight on h3
that's defending that what should I do
yes Bishop takes a string and again we
the first look at the position you think
wow white is just losing my keys losing
he cannot take on h3 if I go pawn takes
Bishop on h3 and the rook takes on f -
this is going to be a very painful
discovered chat you're going to just go
bye-bye but here white missed a very
good news
in the game he played the move g3 maybe
he could have done that but I think that
this is the kind of position we're after
you such have on such heavy fire g2 is
under heavy fire how do you defend both
in one move what do you need to do to
save them and also your unhappy king
your King in the center is not exactly a
happy piece right
so yes Castle he should have counseled
here and if you would have counseled I'm
not exactly sure what would have
happened I think that this it would have
been tricky it would have been very
tricky for block to prove that he is
really as good as we thought he was
White has his own threats on e4 he wants
to play be take c5 and attack the night
and he has Bishop e3 check developing
Caleb so he should have done that
instead he played g3 in itself not a
terrible move but probably not the best
and valo Keating played very
aggressively Queen f6 I'm sure all of
you can see the little visitor on f2
threatening Queen takes after checkmate
now Hikaru should have just played the
move f3 if you would have played f3 and
notice that F 3 is defended many times
by denied by the best by the Queen then
I think that the worst is over after
pawn takes he's not he's not that bad
anymore after all the bishop is under
attack and if this bishop moves my queen
is attacking that bishop so black would
have a lot of proving to do that he can
really justify this all those pieces
that are hanging and I'm not 100% sure
at all that this would have been the
case if he would have really played f3
right now I don't know it would have
been a different kind of game he decided
to play the move Bishop to b3 check
first and that is not a good move even
though it looks like it's getting him an
escape square for the king and it's kind
of developing the bishop that Bishop was
needed on this diagonal now valo heating
just played King h8 and now the king
once again the white king is an unhappy
creature so he did f3 which he had to
and takes now I have a very nasty threat
I want to play f2
and then I want to play f1 and I have a
bishop and a Queen and the rook all
behind it ready for munching very
difficult so I think he calculate the
only move that makes sense before that
one starts advancing let's block it
right now
else the F file is going to open and but
here voila Keaton is already in good
shape
he played Bishop to g5 among the threats
Bishop e3 check very difficult so Knight
x f3 again when we first look at the
position we think to ourselves oh my god
white really managed to somehow save his
miserable position but now who could
tell me what should we play here I can
tell you that they move that black
played was great but he had an even
better move but kind of with the same
idea probably didn't really need to play
the movie replay
let's see if you guys can use your
imagination and tell me what is the best
move in the position take a moment
yes
interesting interesting very interesting
I'm assuming the doctor Pontic see
before you want to play Knight takes e4
and well that's a bit scary I have to
admit but after Eve or maybe I can play
Bishop takes g5 and hit your queen maybe
right again I'm not saying this is the
end of the world but I think that here
block his as a really good position
because the knight on f3 is stuck but we
have a bishop here that's not really
doing any well any anything and not
doing well and is also being attacked by
the Queen in some lines and there is a
great way to revive it but the question
is how I can't display bishop here and I
don't want to play bishop here so what
am I just gonna go all the way with the
bishop or think of a way to revive the
bishop but sometimes we arrive at peace
without touching it you just use
something else to help that piece but
here there's just a move that after
which it's just over well in the game he
played g6
and that was pretty good believe me but
I think that if you would have played
Queen a5 that would have been very very
hard to meet because now the bishop is
incorporated into the game with Bishop
g4 and after that death just very bad
the King can't move because always
Bishop G which g2 and there's no Luke f1
there's just no move in this position
this would have been an instance to win
so anyways after this he played g6 also
not that bad because after Bishop g5
still queen r5 and now yeah desperate
position for white I don't know what you
can do is queen is really in trouble it
can't move so he tried to play Queen
here thinking hey maybe he's gonna be
satisfied with the Queen sacrifice just
take my queen but of course you just
played here and resigned because after
Queen King g1 Queen f2 is mate and if
you go here I take here does that look
happy for white
I don't think so so I think it's a
fantastic game by black-black had really
a lot of fun in this game white went a
little crazy with this idea of queen h5
and paid for it so hope you enjoyed it
now I'm gonna show you one of my
favorite compositions and this is a real
Tuffy I think some of you may have seen
it because it's kind of a famous
position by a composer by the name of
Casper yan he was an Armenian composer
back in Armenia and I really this is one
of my favorites because when you look at
the position you notice that not only is
black two exchanges up but also the pawn
on g5 of it everything is under attack
you think yourself yeah the King on h5
looks a little funny maybe but how bad
can it be right it looks like I can
always give up material even if I give
up a look for two pawns I'm still not
gonna lose as far as material goes and
I'm gonna be okay but this is still a
white to move and win combination and it
looks crazy it looks like how are you
ever going to win it okay I'm always I
mean even if I go like rook takes f4 I
should be able to just break the whole
structure and how am I going to lose
however you will see that yeah this is
losing this is really losing when white
moves so because this is really really
tough I'm going to show it to you and
let's enjoy it together
so the solution 98 okay this is kind of
an easy solution I've been easy first
move because the threat is made I want
to play Knight g7 check King g6 Bishop
f5 checkmate right so not that many
choices you can play King g6 or you can
play rook takes f4 let's try to play
rook takes f4 again sacking the rock now
we will play Knight g7 check King here
now we need to kind of take all the
escape scroll from the king lookup
beautiful chances check how many bigger
moves do you have one then I play Chuck
looks like a crazy move what is he doing
giving his bishop how many legal moves
do you have and then he goes G 4 and
it's gonna be made even though you up to
Brooks against the night there is just
no way you can stop either me taking
this work or this work with mate with a
pump beautiful just beautiful any move
you make move this rook it's made here
move this rook it's made there beautiful
really a beautiful combination so okay
the alternative it's made everywhere
exactly so he's gonna try to run with
his king he's gonna play King here first
now what again it looks like wow this is
like beautiful the King is just running
away and now that looks like there's no
no real mate but h5 check again a
beautiful little sac and again you have
a problem if you take with the king then
my knight is gonna come here with check
giving you no time to do anything else
the King will have to go back here and
then we know that Bishop f5 is made so
he has to take with the rook and now we
play oops sorry
now we play f5 check exactly right and
now of course the rock has to take it
now I'm going to play g4 threatening
Bishop takes f5 checkmate so you can't
afford to move the rook on the h-file at
all
so let's pretend that you will move your
look away and not only that you're going
to move it to a position where you're
threatening checkmate on your own of
your own you're threatening now
checkmate
but now white wins the same way we saw
before just a beautiful little win again
a little destruction giving up the
bishop I know what I have to do only one
legal move take it and then Knight g7
closing the mate net once again and on
any rook move there's going to be pawn
taking the other rook with mate so if
you move this guy this is mate if you
move this guy this is mate
what a brilliant composition were a
knight and one pawn in the middle of the
our bidding two rocks and three points
just because the poor King is stuck on a
wrong square did you understand that
whoa now we are going to play some
chests because you pay for them